[Música]
siempre y cuando nos invitan pues
siempre es una conferencia formal que
tenemos que sentar y contarles una
historia sobre el camino de santiago yo
nomás os voy a explicar para el tema que
me llamaron hoy aquí seis minutos
explicar lo que lo que hace cambiar en
la vida el camino de santiago nuestra
institución data de hace muchos siglos
pero ya adaptada a los tiempos de ahora
tenemos tenemos presencia en 25 países
somos más de más de 1000 caballeros y yo
no os voy a hablar cómo cambian las
vidas al realizar el camino de santiago
como nace porque nació el camino de
santiago el camino de santiago nació
porque aparecieron en el campo de las
estrellas los restos del apóstol
santiago allá por el año 813 a partir de
ahí empiezan las peregrinaciones de todo
el mundo por el famoso por todas las
rutas no por el camino francés por este
pueblo camino del norte pues también es
una de las etapas por donde discurre y
cuando hay mucha gente que como nosotros
decimos el camino de santiago es el
camino de las estrellas el camino de
santiago es la calle principal de europa
porque porque aquí concurren todas las
civilizaciones cuando tú pasas por tanto
van vas a santiago encuentras de todas
las nacionalidades como bien sabéis en
nuestra institución somos de 25 países
hoy estábamos ya hablando que puede
haber un país más o dos
speaker o conferenciante que está hoy
aquí pues también formará parte para el
año que viene de nuestra institución
pero cómo cambia el camino a la gente
ya desde el año 813 hasta hoy millones
de peregrinos y dice me cambio el camino
de santiago el que me en santiago mucha
gente empieza por deporte otra gente
empieza bueno pues está de moda y mucha
gente dice ante unos grandes problemas
que yo tuve en mi vida me ofrezco a
realizar el camino de santiago el camino
de santiago
te cura no te cura tu cuerpo te cubre tu
mente por eso invito a toda la gente a
que empiece a caminar por el camino de
santiago como peregrino no como
caminante el caminante coge un camino y
no sabe a dónde va un peregrino inicia
una ruta y sabe un destino isabel am
sabe realmente a lo que va yo me ofrezco
a que todos los que realicen el camino
de santiago seguro que siempre dicen mi
vida se transformó supere los problemas
que tenía porque siempre nos acordamos
de los problemas de santa bárbara cuando
realmente cuando trona nos acordamos de
santiago apostol realmente pues cuando
hay un problema cuando hay un problema
siempre una muerte en la familia y tengo
que superar eso como lo supero pues el
camino de santiago te inspira yo empiezo
a caminar en el camino no te encuentras
no eres forastero porque hay de todas
las nacionalidades
unos nos ayudamos a otro si tienes un
problema te ayudan si te caes te ayudan
a levantarte si tú te encuentras mal
los propios peregrinos que son tus
compañeros que no los conoces de nada
allí hay la mayor humildad no hay ricos
ni pobres todos somos iguales ahí te
ayudan psicológicamente son tus
psicólogos los que es una consulta
gratuita y diaria ellos se cuentan por
qué camino porque yo me ofrecí porque
hace unos días un diputado muy famoso de
un partido que no sepa hablar de
política ni de religión de un partido
muy famoso pues que caminaba con su
mujer y dije tuvo que ir al médico
porque notaba seguido hay algo divino
que le ayudó pablo casado si su niño
nació con seis meses y se ofreció hace
muchos años dijo tengo que hacer el
camino porque el camino y dijo me
encuentro en este momento como estoy
cumpliendo que en aquel momento me
encontraba muy flojo muy mal y sin
embargo supere esa crisis y me vengo
ofrecer de vengo ofrecer y vengo a hacer
el camino lo recibimos nosotros hace dos
semanas pero así muchísima gente cuando
dices me transformó mi vida es el camino
de la ilusión por eso yo siempre digo
comienza a hacer el camino
no tengas miedo no lleves grandes pesos
llevan a más la ilusión cuando tú
llegues a compostela
realmente es cuando tú si es tu
despertar te abrazas al apóstol y tú
dices he cumplido la misión no ese es
una etapa de tu vida porque el camino
realmente de santiago no es no es un
camino es realmente un camino físico que
existe por las diferentes rutas pero es
el camino de tu vida yo lo que te digo
el camino realmente es el camino que tú
haces en todo momento el camino de
superación pensar siempre en positivo
nunca cuando tú tengas argumentos bajos
como tuvo el apóstol santiago la
apareció la virgen en la virgen del
pilar en zaragoza pues tú cuando tengas
momentos difíciles también te invocas al
apóstol te superas te consigues
levantarte apartar todos los momentos
difíciles y buscas siempre lo positivo
en la forma de triunfar
y si tenéis algún problema en la vida
ofrece tal apóstol y camina y ahí habrá
mucha gente como vosotros que os
ayudarán que estará siempre a vuestro
lado que te superará lo importante de
todo aparte de la gastronomía de la
cultura de la de la arquitectura de todo
eso yo te digo que el camino realmente
es el camino de la ilusión el camino que
nos gusta a todos de superar y ya veréis
como si seguimos así no sólo será un
fenómeno cultural sino será un fenómeno
de superación de curar a aquellas
personas todas que tengan momentos bajos
en la vida esa gente que la ves de caída
que la ves ya hundida porque la
resiliencia es te dices tú es el momento
de superar y superar a los momentos
difíciles os animo a que haga es el
camino y allí encontraréis realmente la
felicidad muchas gracias
[Aplausos]